kick in then so the
webcast
could take place so
on that point could i just uh remind
everybody to please use the microphone
so that they can be fed on the webcast
um so welcome to this uh
meeting of health and scrutiny
committee and
for those who don't know me
i'm counsellor michael wetton um and
i've been
appointed to the uh
chair of this committee
um
in place of counsellor former councillor
uh dr barclay
um
karen barkley stepped down from the
council at the beginning of
january
for
various reasons including the fact that
she moved home
and
is no longer actually a trafford
resident
and she felt that
it was an appropriate time for her to
um to leave leave the council
i would like to ask if the committee
would
be minded to agree to
send a letter of thanks to
karen barkley for her service
to uh
to health scrutiny
um and i say that because i don't think
trafford actually is very good at
sending letters of thanks to people um
so um
as far as i'm aware because i never
served on this committee with her so as
i'm aware uh karen did
um sterling service on the committee and
um i think it would be appropriate for
her to receive something
something from us so if
that's okay we'll we'll go along
um that route yeah i would sack in that
chair yeah absolutely thank
you um
so on to the agenda to
attendances and
we have received apologies from
councillor denise weston
councillor cordingly councillor chilton
councillor carr
and we were hoping to have uh councillor
harding here but
uh we've received her apologies as as
well
i'm just checking
yeah that's all the apologies we've
received
and i think we
did get word that council action was not
likely to be able to turn myself i have
received apologies from council acton as
well right so that's the apologies there
okay
so that virtually covers the
committee membership
anyway just one that we've not heard
from
so item two is the minutes
of the meeting that was held on the 17th
of november
2021 which we need to agree is a correct
record i cannot
possibly comment as i was not there so
council hartley you
moving
thank you chair i think i think um i
would like to suggest the correction
which is right near the end of the
minutes on page five
um
so i think i think there's a bit of a
mix up between
um item 28 and 29 so
sorry item 28 was the report i gave on
the poverty action group work and then
at item 29
uh the minister committee considered the
following topics for review uh housing
what role the council takes into
inclusion and credit union one-stop
shops
so i think some of the things that are
at 29 were questions that members of the
committee posed to me
after i'd given the report so i'm not
sure we did agree
there was items
at um
number 29 to be topics for the committee
to review i think there were questions
to me which
um
i've emailed the answers to actually ran
to members now i don't know that accords
with other members recollections
[Music]
no
i think those
topics relate to item 28 yeah yeah
okay so can we know those
changes are required and
other than that can we
agree the minutes
yeah
thank you
item 3 is declaration
of
interest members need to give notice of
any interest um
is there any
decorations needed
thank you
um
sorry sorry did you see um i'm a trustee
of traffic domestic abuse services
right thank you
thanks
item 4's urgent business and i do not
have any
so
item five
then is had a social care
update as i said we were hoping to have
um
councillor harding here uh diane eaton
is going to
um deal with this matter
for us
thank you lovely uh thank you chair
um and uh joanne to send her apologies
tonight she would have
liked to have been with us but she's
presenting um
around social care in a a national event
and
we wanted to bring an update because as
you will be aware we introduced a
decision-making framework around
allocation of resources in social care
based on the considerable demand being
placed on us in relation to the
omnichrome variant and this wave of
covid 19.
and that has been in place for two and a
half weeks now and that was as a result
of the national ask which came through
to prepare for a lot of staff at 10 20
and 30 percent
now as you can imagine ten percent's
just like the over normal average
sickness which is around about five to
six percent in most services but twenty
percent and thirty percent absences was
was extremely worrying so in preparation
for that we did a lot of work with all
of our providers to put to make sure
their business continuity plans were
refreshed and strong
this is the hardest um wave of this
pandemic that we have ever faced
worse than march 20 in my view
and so the services were extremely
supportive and really thinking about how
they were going to cover such traffic
losses
using agency using overtime support from
volunteers etc we also established in
the council of hr resourcing hub that
volunteers from across the council
committed to support any of our
providers should they not be able to
provide essential and
services for people that could not be
managed in a different way we had over
70 volunteers across the council who
were willing to be redeployed into care
home settings etc which was really
supportive and really helpful
so um what the framework enabled me to
do
but was to have some a decision-making
framework to to log and record all the
decisions that we had to make and make
quite quickly
and as the infection um spread through
our community
leading up to christmas
we did a phenomenal amount of work with
manchester foundation trust and salford
foundation trust to the two hospitals
that you know we work very closely with
we supported around 416 people across
manchester and trafford to leave
hospital and go home which enabled the
hospitals to have the capacity required
to take the increased activity that was
forecast for them leading into christmas
however that left us in a difficult
position in january with limited
resources
and as we moved through into january we
found that our
home care providers were not taking any
new referrals because they needed to
make sure they maximised support to
those people we currently supported
and our care homes were finding that
their staffing levels without breaks
that were affecting their own staff were
meaning that they were closed closing to
admissions
so at the height of the first second
week in january we had around 70 of our
care homes closed to admission which
meant we had very little resource
to access for people needing to leave
hospital
and people needing to step up from
community
our home care providers we worked with
them but many of them handed packages
back at short notice
because they felt that they couldn't
resource them we managed to move
packages around which did mean that
people received different carers and
different suppliers
um but we were able to source all of the
high-risk packages
as part of the business continuity
planning we worked with the providers so
that they have a traffic light system so
if somebody has family that live very
close or we can supply a meal delivery
and reduce one visit etc we use those
kind of options to support us to ensure
that the the people that had to have
personal care support
food medication etc um were maximized
for the support that was available
and i have to say as your
director of social care it was the most
difficult eight weeks
i have faced through the whole of the
pandemic
but i'm very proud to tell you that the
homes and the staff managed it really
really well so today
we have 15 homes closed
which is amazing that's out of 54.
and so the rest 39 are taking admissions
and as has increased over this period of
time we've got 244 places in the homes
available but not all of them are
accessible because they are still being
quite cautious on the way that they
manage it
we have six homes on what we're calling
a red and number watch list that we're
just concerned around their staffing
particularly where registered managers
have been managing some of this now for
two years and they're very tired but
keeping a really close eye and close to
those two those six services
and we've got staff returning to work um
and so and we have all the way through
this wave
and had very low numbers of residents in
care hopes who have been very ill so we
have had outbreaks and they have had an
infection but there have not been as
many hospitalizations as we saw in the
first few waves
so today we have 24 residents in care
homes who are who are posit testing
positive
and but we haven't had as many
admissions
and
we have our home care services now
starting to take
referrals again and our hospital
discharge work is starting to pick up
so i'm reporting back though that you
have really clear transparent overview
of we have had longer delays of people
waiting to leave hospital than we would
have liked to have had and that reached
a point of 60 people waiting in the
first two weeks of january however
that's come back down and we're at about
38 today and it's dropping each day
last week we managed to discharge 51
people
and this week we're at 44 today and
we've still got tomorrow it's um it's
it's getting better
we have done a rag rating in our
position which was submitted to greater
manchester each each week
i'm leaving that at red for our
commissioned provision because two weeks
is not enough a sustainable position yet
for me to to feel that we can reduce
that however our in-house services were
reduced to amber
our social work services are on amber
but their level of referral activity is
really really high so we're just doing a
further piece of work with them this
week and then we may need to bring in
some additional capacity around social
work assessment
to to handle the number of uh referrals
coming in
and are the people waiting for home care
now um has dropped to around 55 today we
were we had 80 people 90 people at one
point um in the first week of january
waiting for home care so you can see um
committee that the
the activity is phenomenal and but the
resources are being maximized and to
make sure we meet the highest need it is
settling but it's going to take a little
time i think
one of the things that i've reflected on
is that the frame that we put for
framework we put in place
um enables that if i needed to ramp up
to um what we call open level 4 which
would be a level of a critical incident
i would have council support on the
decisions that i was making would be
able to log those and report those into
yourselves
the framework has not been utilized as
as i
hoped it wouldn't but you know when
it may have been needed
and
in another week and a half i will then
work with joe harding and and come back
to you at the next committee to let you
know whether we we can close that
framework down
and which i hope we can but what we we
would recommend is if there is another
way if that framework would then be
enacted again
and and just to thank everyone for your
support because i know
members of the committee have
flagged up individuals to me that we've
needed to check on and we've been able
to do that which it's been really really
supportive and thank you chair if
there's any questions
so thank you very much for that it was
um
worrying to you say that that was the
most difficult period of the
pandemic today that you've just gone
through so
um
positive news from you at the end at the
end of that and obviously our thanks to
all of the staff that
um have been involved in that
um
that particular pressure period
i think that what what i'm
mindful of i'm noticing that people
public public people are
seem to be becoming inured to the
uh the pandemic
the the death figures just don't seem to
raise an eyebrow anymore
um there was a very high figure
published yesterday which
um
caused me to wince um
but it doesn't seem to become a
an
item for the media to cover so very much
uh anymore
um
so
i think it is important that
we do hear word like you've just
delivered about the stresses that are
still there
uh and and the deaths
the death figures
added to that um this is
although that
it's being
proclaimed that we we're through it um
we don't know yet do we
who knows what
um
variant can can emerge
next and i'm not
um being doom and gloom there i'm just
being very mindful that this
pandemic has taken us by surprise a
number of times already so
um
thank you very much for for that update
and uh are there any questions from any
members of the committee
counselor
taylor
can i just thank you very much for that
report diane and um echo what councillor
wetton has said in terms of uh thanking
you and all of your team and
the wider
social care service for the incredible
work that you've done over this period
of time and i'm really glad to hear that
you haven't had to enact the strategy in
full but um and i know that was a very
very difficult decision that you had to
make but i think it's it's very much uh
to you to your credit and the the
leadership of the council's credit that
that strategy was put in place um rather
than sort of leave things to chance
really and he had that vision to to um
to have that in place should it be
required and hopefully you won't need to
enact a point can i just ask you one
question um you just said um the social
work referrals were on an amber rating
at the moment and you're looking to
create some additional capacity uh for
social work assessments how how is that
how are you proposing to do that at the
moment um so
thank you for the feedback
generally that that is really helpful um
the
the difficulty at the moment
across the whole of social care and i
think i think for health colleagues it's
very similar is that the workforce is
very depleted
we've got pressures coming over the hill
around mandatory vaccinations which um
the first dose requirement is next week
and so that is causing us considerable
concern as well around some of our home
care provision particularly
um
and so
for
the recruitment of social workers i will
i will need to go to an agency but the
recruitment through agency at the moment
is not particularly good and so we are
looking at a couple of companies that
that come in and do specific pieces of
work for you rather than come and take a
case load because what i don't want to
do is bring people in for long term case
work that are only here for a short
period of time because that creates
inconsistencies so i'm just looking at
the options at the moment and but that
may be approached so for instance we
for everyone who receives the service we
complete a reassessment every year to
make sure everything's okay and we did a
lot of virtual work in the first 18
months of the pandemic and this year we
have insisted that needs to be face to
face so we might bring in some
additional capacity to pick up that work
freeing up and the social work capacity
to deal with any income in demand so
that may be one option
and just going back to the framework
that we put in place one of the things
that i considered when uh working with
joe hardy on this was
when we had the fire at trafford general
it was a critical incident we responded
very quickly we took decisions that
night so iraq i found myself taught
decisions that to move people very very
quickly into care homes or wherever was
suitable but that was a one-off incident
that happened as an emergency and it was
very short and contained
this
felt like it was going to take a number
of months to work our way through so it
felt
best practice
and more transparent and open to use the
framework approach
thank you
thanks very much
councillor blackburn yeah
thank you um
because um
there are you know obviously pressures
on on on staff and staff have been
covering for other staff
if
they've not been able to take leave will
they be permitted to carry it over into
the new financial year
oh thank you councillor blackburn yes
very good question so certainly in the
council we we permit a carryover of
leave and i know in in health it's
similar and in our private
contract providers we are working within
some actual people access leave and i
think that's partly why we're seeing a
slower
step back up because people that work
through christmas are then taking leave
off and the providers are very conscious
of trying to spread that out so they can
manage their resources
but also conscious that they need to
look after the staff that they've got
and so we're working closely with them
yeah
any more questions for dan
okay thank you
so we'll move on then to item five
b and
i think you're going to introduce this
well aren't you dan
thank you thank you chair um so um
scrutiny asked for an update on the um
information and advice services offered
by
um trafford and so the report and i
won't go through it because i i know you
will have looked at it but the report
details the services um
that we that we provide but we we did
start a piece of strategy review work
just leading into the pandemic but that
was that was paused because we needed to
move all the resources you can imagine
the increased activity around um
information and welfare rights uh type
support
and we are picking that back up but we
have extended some of the commission
services to give us time to do that with
members
and so we have services um in the
council and access trafford where people
are struggling to pay rent housing
benefit discretionary housing payments
council tax issues etc but they also
sign point sign post all of the incoming
inquiries regarding social care and to
make sure that we're and they then able
to provide um assessments
trafford assist where we've got welfare
assistance schemes immediate short-term
needs are met financially where people
are struggling and then we have um a
commissioned um
welfare rights provision through
citizens advice bureau and a couple of
smaller specialist services and
particular groups and then our internal
welfare rights team
and which deal with the more complex
situations and what we've done is given
you a little bit of a flavor on each of
those services and then some more
details information around the internal
welfare rights uh services and outcomes
and we thought we will find tonight that
sort of if you want to have more detail
in any particular one area and we can
then bring further information back and
anne marie hideon is here who is our
lead for this internal welfare rights
services if we have any detailed and
difficult questions thank you
thank you
council hartley
thank you chair and thank you um diana
for bringing this paper and and and to
colleagues um
i first of all i i just wanted to say i
thought the last um
a couple of pages which sort of outlined
the
the commission providers and what we
have in-house was really useful so
that's the sort of thing i've been
trying to navigate for the
two years since i was elected and uh so
i'd definitely recommend it that it
would form part of a you know a new
councillor induction um i thought it was
really useful um i had
a couple of related questions which were
to do with the
um debt advice and financial advice
offer
um
and at the at the last meeting we um
there was there was a question about the
idea of sort of a one-stop shop for debt
advice that might not be a perfect way
to describe it actually but i think
i think what uh
what we were getting at or what i was
getting at was is there um
so
the the scenario that
i'd want to avoid would be somebody goes
to a bank you know with a debt problem
you know they don't get help they go to
a credit union they don't get help
and then you'd want that person to be
referred into the services that that we
offer so i just wanted is that part of
either the in-house or the commission
services that we
provide information to credit unions and
uh banks or the providers so that if a
trafford resident finds himself at a
dead end they don't sort of resort to
the
um you know the the lone sharks they
would they would come to you and get the
advice that they need
um if i start off the memory may want to
add so part of the strategy review was
to try and make sure that all all of the
systems were connected together so um
there's been a an it solution which
gives the services ability to actually
be able to uh track if you like that
people are getting the right help and
which we are part way through um
in instigating and we have
tried to root everything through
citizens advanced bureau so that they
can then filter things into the right
place
um because if you have got a particular
need that stops you then getting the
right type of advice we need to bring
the specialists in for the right people
but not for everybody if that makes
sense
part of the strategy work is to develop
that further and so i would say it's not
fully there at
where it needs to be
more work is needed to make sure that we
can do what you've just described but
that is the ambition
and that we would have one place that
people come to and then ability to bring
in specialists required required at each
point
and um
sorry chad just just to follow up on
that is is there um
is there a role in there as well for i
know a lot of housing providers will
have their own debt advisors financially
including officers so
it's the same point really you know that
people don't if they get to a dead end
with that with that advice that you know
it gets referred into the service yeah
so i can come in on that um in terms of
the debt advisors and the housing
associations they work really closely
together and they're part of the um
strategic group in terms of the
development plans
and citizens advice also offer that
advice work and the debt advisors do
liaise directly with the debtors around
negotiations around around pavement of
debt and internally as well we currently
have a trainee debt advisor who can't
practice as a an official qualified debt
advisor as of yet but is training and to
do so and being offered supervision as
well through the housing association so
there's very clear links in that respect
[Music]
council
actually i just wanted to ask about the
specialist debt um the debt specialist
where were they at with the training and
once they've been able to do it how
will that impact with do they actually
go and represent people in a court case
do they negotiate how they pay back the
money
in terms of once they're fully qualified
yes they could represent in court and
unfortunately i've been advised this
week that the
trainee debt advisor has handed in their
notice so we will be
recruiting to that role again to support
that trainee role in moving that forward
oh that's a shame how long does it take
normally i'm just thinking of you next
person who comes on board and this is
the first trial that we've had um
internally and so
with covert it has delayed it um
unfortunately i'd have to go and check
in terms of the normal training regime
in terms of time scales and things but
i'm happy to bring that back if required
okay thanks
and in the interim we'll use debt
advisors in cab
we just wanted to have to try and have
our own in-house people as well to
expand the welfare rights offer
council lied
um
sorry diane you said that you want to
expand the um welfare rights um team to
how much because
i noticed that welfare advice is only
opened between 9 00 and 1 pm when shot
just wondered
if that was enough
and
i've got another question and cab are
there any problems in people being able
to
contact them because i know there have
been problems in the past because i
think they've just been overwhelmed
and um
i'm concerned because
we've had a lot of people uh referred in
but i expect there will be more referred
in um come april uh due to the changes
um in natural insurance
fuel
a lot of people are going to be put into
um
dire circumstances
so is there capacity within in the
system to take these on
um given that also you have very complex
cases i know
um
so it's about three there
and thank you councillor lloyd a really
really good questions and we're tracking
all of the activity and referrals coming
in um and part of our
planning around resilience and and we've
had money called um covered contain
money which gives us additional capacity
we have put in support whereas needed
and i agree with you i think we are
going to see a a significant increase in
referral activity and so part of the
work that amerie is leading with all of
those services together is to make sure
that we're aware when that when
referrals are coming through in the
can't manage capacity so that we can
expand we are waiting for announcements
around the national funding around the
contain fund
into next year but we're trying to work
out what we can do now that gives us
that capacity working through and so
yes i share your concern but we're
tracking and monitoring
to enable us to step in and increase
capacity where required
and i haven't had any um information
around access issues recently and we
know it was an issue but we've worked
really hard with this supplier but i'll
ask anne-marie to come in on on that
point
and just to refer to the point in
relation to the advice line within the
welfare rights team and prior to covert
when we first initiated the strategy the
view was that we were going to
disestablish that line with all the like
um calls going into citizen's advice and
but we reopened that line to help
support the covert response and so that
will be a point which is reviewed
through the strategy and going back to
diane's earlier point about the one one
point of entry in terms of phone calls
etc into getting advice
and in terms again around the issues
with contacting cab i myself have not
had any reports of that recently and but
obviously that's something we could look
at with our commissioning colleagues
with their tracking of the work of of
call rates etc into the service
[Music]
and just want to say thank you for the
report is being you know really really
useful for us so thank you um just one
uh question on um
1.4.5 you reference the um the kind of
the income gains that have been
generated over an eight month period and
that's um you know it seems like an
incredibly impressive number to me so
you know commend your team for doing
that i just wondered is there any kind
of benchmark for what good looks like in
in terms of you know generating income
per person
and
in terms of the benchmarking i
personally am not aware of any other um
benchmarking
available but that's something that we
can definitely look into and the
senior advice officer links in very
closely to all the other welfare rights
teams within the northwest and within
greater manchester so we can look into
that and come back with that information
thank you that's appreciated it's just
you know it looks incredibly impressive
but as you know you've indicated you're
expecting demand to rise
this year so just whatever we can do i
guess thank you
again thank you very much for that it's
really really useful um just i mean
obviously there is no shortage of
businesses there to to this service but
i just wonder how do you um publicize
that this is a service that because i
think people wouldn't necessarily think
this is the council was their first port
of call if they wanted um advice on
welfare rights you obviously offer a
really
extensive service and if you go on the
council website
you know there's it can it can lead you
to the welfare rights landing page
there's if you put in debt advice
there's nothing specific there is there
about um that advice
do you think there's any i mean
obviously not short of work but um do
you think there's any need to sort of
publicize this work any further to
ensure that
people are accessing the service
thank you and
it's always a it's always a question
isn't it we could always do more would
be my would be my initial answer and as
as the support that um people need
increases
the welfare rights service is focusing
on the on the very complex situations
usually where there is um risk of
homelessness etc and
so the cab
services filter people through so we
will always have a flow of people coming
through for welfare provision
and
it it would be very nice to be able to
extend the in-house provision but we do
need to be mindful of the funding we
have available and we need to make sure
that the specialist support that they're
able to offer is targeted and i think so
i think we're cautious around
advertising very openly but we have the
filters
from those other services coming through
and the um decision to open the helpline
was at a point where um activity was it
was increasing and we will keep it open
until we feel that we've got
enough provision across the sector and i
think i think you know to be fair i
think we've probably got another year
before we see the pandemic um
out of the way properly and with all of
the economic impact that it's had on
people that that's going to have quite a
tale to it isn't it i think i think
we've got um a lot of work to do for the
next couple of years
could i ask could i ask one follow-up
question the point about counsellor
induction
was was really um helpful i think i'm
just wondering whether
if we put this into a little pack
whether we could add that into the
council of induction um because we'd be
happy to do that and then we could keep
that up to date for you
and sometimes just knowing who to talk
to
is helpful isn't it if you have somebody
that you're worried about
we'll erase that uh yes if that could be
passed on to uh ian cockell he's the one
who puts the induction back together
lovely thank you
okay thank you for that and councillor
blackbeard
thank you could i ask um
have any of the registered social
landlords stopped offering welfare
rights advice
that we know of
not that i'm aware of at the moment and
i haven't been advised of that okay
right and
so
are are there are those
presumably those tenants will be
getting
advice that they need from if they are
you know
a tenant of a particular housing
association
um would would you be able to get some
you know feedback on on that whether or
not um you know they are and and sort of
what what kind of um you know numbers
are accessing their their services
thank you
if we take that question away chair
[Music]
can i just ask a couple of questions for
me um we had a reference to on page six
to
uh
1.45
about the
success
story there
and i just wondered um
i mean that's a significant amount of
money there for for every one of those
um people if you look at the average
uh and the and the total
and it's
it's a good news story
very often
government issues figures about the
benefits that haven't been claimed the
quantity
of cash quantity that has as yet been
unclaimed against their estimates i
wondered has that ever been split down
into sort of a borough
figure do would we know if if there's a
figure
a calculation for trafford
of benefits that haven't been
been claimed and i'm sure you've not
got that answer at your fingertips
no we haven't we'll link we'll make some
inquiries see if we can find out um but
i've not heard it that's specifically
delivered
it's it's just um it would be
interesting to know i don't i don't want
to create a load of hard work for um
people
uh on that but um another point if i
could just ask on the
um
on the commission providers
in figure one the details have broken
down there and i've just had to remind
myself that we're in year 2022 so i see
that
all of those contractual arrangements
are ending shortly
um what's the situation going forward
with those
thank you chair and with the um current
situation we have agreed an extension
for 12 months
um and we that was
enabled by the way we've procured them
so we have a usually a couple of years
procurement with the next option to
extend if they're delivering and they
are all delivering very well in the
current circumstances and so we are
extending them
i know if there's no more questions i'll
just
conclude this item by saying
i think it's very encouraging to see
such a
comprehensive um
net is out there to help people
albeit in what is a very difficult area
a very difficult area for
individuals and a
very difficult area in sometimes in
finding ways to to help individuals so
certainly um commend all the work that's
being done there and um
take a great deal of satisfaction from
the the good news stories that are that
are recorded there
so thank you very much to
to all involved with that
so conclude that item then um we'll move
on to the
um
sorry uh dan if if you and anne marie
want to uh
take you leave you
you won't yeah marie might leave shortly
but i'll stay for the for the whole
committee okay thank you
um
so we move on then to
item six the council's role as a gateway
to securing housing for residents
including homeless residents and it's uh
adrian fisher
uh
thank you chair and good evening
councillors um
uh yes i hopefully this item will follow
on quite uh neatly from uh uh the matter
we've just been discussing um
uh as you can see that the report
considers uh the role that the council
has uh as a gateway uh to ensuring that
um residents can access adequate housing
and particularly uh those at risk of of
homelessness
um the the context for this is from a
health perspective of course is that
there's a very well established link
between
good housing and good health and indeed
the
the converse is true as well so so the
more that we can uh help our residents
uh get into uh adequate housing that
meets their needs then hopefully also um
the better the health outcomes
so the um the background um for this
really is just i suppose that the the
position of housing
within uh trafford and that's one where
owner occupation does predominate much
more than
most areas of greater manchester so 69
percent of uh
of homes are uh
in owner occupation
and those are also
a probably significantly higher price
than the norm again across great
manchester so
higher levels of of cost
um involved for for buying a home but
also for renting a home as well and most
of those rental costs exceed um
the the relevant allowances as well
now against that we do have units of uh
affordable accommodation um and you'll
see there are almost 16 000 of those um
and
trafford no longer is a housing
authority itself so we don't own any
housing stock um and so we are very much
um dependent on our partners in the
registered providers
so really the the what the report
concentrates on is is is how we operate
our system of allocating uh people to uh
the right type of housing
and the priorities that we use uh
involving that stock that is is is held
by others
so in terms of the uh the housing
allocations policy um i mean it's a
statutory approach um and
we have to follow a process of
reasonable uh preference and um
that that applies to
to people that um
uh are in certain um categories so in
particular those are people who are um
at risk of of homelessness or indeed
facing direct homelessness um and i'll
explain go on to explain kind of the
categories uh of residents in involved
in that
um but there are others as well so there
may be some through our our work through
the environmental health team
where we encounter on occasion um unfit
housing
um and again they are um accorded a
preference um but there may also be um
folk who um because of a
medical condition um also need um to
change their housing and again they they
are
afforded a preference
so you'll see from the report that we
operate a five um
a system of five bands um
and really in in simple terms that you
know the higher you are
up there um the more chance you are of
of accessing uh a home
um and so um you know it is
uh those particularly really within
bands one two and three um that are have
perhaps the most opportunity to access
homes um and in
four and five accordingly uh rather less
so
so in terms of the types of property um
that we have available um
you can see those set out in in in the
table there so um quite a lot of smaller
properties so one of the issues we have
is that if there are people in need who
have need bigger properties
there are quite a
rather less of those generally um and
you can also then see
at 3.6 the the kind of
mix of
different applicants according to
uh to band
now i mentioned earlier we're highly
dependent on our partners within the um
[Music]
affordable housing sector so our
registered
providers
and
the way that
we are able to
access their housing is through the
nominations agreement
and um that's essentially a an agreement
that
when people come to us we can then
channel them to to those particular
providers
and and you'll see that whilst there are
um
34 separate registered providers
operating in the borough um
we have some fairly um big players as
you'll be aware so trafford housing
trust in particular who who took over
um uh what was the the former trafford
um
uh council housing for the most part but
then we also have erwell valley and your
housing group uh again probably uh
legacy a lot of their stock is is legacy
from
uh various sources um so they provide
that they're that they're the big
players but we do have a big variety uh
within uh within the borough
um
so in
in terms of the table there 4.6 um you
can see a breakdown of um
the type of applicants that we have
coming forward
obviously tending to have more in the
lower bands than the higher ones
um
and generally um that the need is more
around the smaller properties so the one
and two bedroom properties
and in terms of the way
the those are channeled through
registered providers um we are getting
uh a good level of take-up so you can
see that that the percentage of
successful nominations is running at the
high 90 percents so that's good news
that means that um
uh that when we are putting people
forward generally um that's working out
and they are taking up those properties
with the housing provider
now one of the main um uh duties that
the authority has is around um
homelessness
um
[Music]
and essentially really that that works
in in probably three ways
um so there's first of all uh a
prevention duty
so that is where somebody um
[Music]
is a is at risk of of of homelessness
um
and um you know that they perhaps can
perceive that they have a depending on
the circumstances
uh a threat to their their housing
situation and we have a duty um uh to
assist those
um and there's a 56 period 56-day period
in order to do that
there is then um if
people
aren't assisted in that time a relief
duty
which is is 56 days again and then if
people are um fortunate to fall into you
know literally have nowhere to live then
then they fall into the main duty
um
and
uh you can see from the table that you
know the numbers of of of people falling
into
each of each of those um categories and
people are afforded a higher preference
and a higher banding according to where
they sit
in that um in that hierarchy um so
obviously the those who are most in need
um get the the higher preference
now in in addition to um
tackling um
you know those those particular duties
around homelessness um
the uh council through its uh housing
options service or the host service who
run uh all of this
that team will also um offer housing
advice um so really being a bit more
proactive around trying to help people
um with uh with with their housing
um
and um
we will also have a support uh provision
as well um so we have um five tenancy
support workers
and and they are i suppose trying to
ensure that when people do get into
housing they make the success of that um
that they're able to to stay there that
you know able to run and manage um
themselves within that setting um
because some of the uh the residents who
who are
allocated housing may well have quite
complex needs they may be quite
vulnerable um and therefore um the more
they can be supported in that
accommodation
the better so we do have a system of
tenancy support workers to ensure that
people can maintain their tenancy
successfully
now when we talk about
um i suppose one of the perhaps most
visible things that perhaps in the
public's eye they may perceive is is
around rough sleeping um
now we do have rough sleeping um to a
degree within trafford but but you can
see from the table there in section
seven
that the numbers are really very small
indeed which is is is good news is um
uh and some of those um are really quite
entrenched so
people who
have effectively been
offered assistance over
a number of years in some cases but for
whom they prefer that as a as a
lifestyle choice
we do have a system we have a rough
sleeper outreach workers and then there
is a um
the the bed every night uh provision
which is um a great manchester
initiative designed to ensure that
people you know are not um
you know do have somewhere to go
um
whatever their circumstances
i suppose um finally just to say that i
mean when we're talking about
um
[Music]
all of these different initiatives
all of that is really dependent on
ensuring that we have a pipeline of
housing that we have enough housing and
we have you know places of the the right
kind of provision in order to direct
people so just briefly to mention the
the you know some of the work that the
housing team will also do is around
ensuring we we do have that pipeline of
new affordable housing um
and one way that's done is through the
trafford affordable housing fund um and
that has a link through to the planning
system so um
on occasion it's not possible always to
provide
affordable housing uh on site as a new
development um and and those uh and if
that's the case then a financial
contribution uh has to be made
and this fund enables those
contributions to be pulled and then
directed to particular projects and
members may be aware that um
the uh of the scheme at bowker court in
timperley uh with the provision of 30
new um
social rent affordable homes is an
example of that that's where it's sort
of coming to fruition and you know more
of that will be uh in the pipeline in
future years
um so i hope that provides an overview
of uh
the responsibilities and and the way
that the council responds to those and
um be very happy to take any questions
uh thank you chair
thank you cateracanola
thank you for the report and i
i'm really pleased that there has been
some new initiative like balco that have
come on board and but looking at the
figures what really concerns me and what
i'd like to know a little bit more about
how we're going to address this is when
we've got six and a half thousand people
applicants on a waiting list
and we're
approximately 482 in a year
roughly that's 13 years if the list was
to stand still before those people would
be accommodated what's being done to
try and address that
thank you yeah
absolutely i mean there is there is of
course a you know there is a huge
mismatch between
uh supply and demand um i think there
are a couple of things that that are
being done one one is um through the
council's planning responsibilities
ensuring that we get um enough homes
built so
there's a government-wide target um as
for the numbers of homes overall
uh that need to be built in the borough
um and um
where and alongside that a percentage of
those um will be
affordable
um
and you'll be aware that we we have
the trafford local plan but also
importantly the
places for everyone plan
and those are advancing now and they
will ensure that we have up-to-date
policies to ensure we get the right kind
of percentages also we have the right
amount of housing built in the future
the council also through its own
investments
is being quite proactive in this area so
we have sites such as um
sale magistrates court or the former
sale magistrates court which is being
redeveloped now for housing um the the
council's involved in joint ventures in
a number of locations so where there's
there's a current scheme uh alongside
stratford mall for example where again
this is the council being kind of
proactive using its own assets um we
have the kellogg site across the road of
course again which was um an employment
site predominantly and will be mixed use
with affordable housing in future
um so we have all of that and then as i
say the um
we have the um
um
uh
the the affordable housing fund uh as as
well so really it is about trying to do
everything we can in terms of our
statutory responsibilities but also
where there are opportunities to be more
proactive um to take that as well on top
can i just ask is there any opportunity
for us as a council where much to say
because i don't know what we have but
some landing give preferable terms to a
social provider who would provide
social and affordable housing rather
than
i mean at the moment
property developers go out and buy land
and they build what they're going to
make the most
profit on and i'm wondering is there
something where the council has land
where it's dictated particularly that it
would be for social and affordable
housing only but in much bigger numbers
than 33.
yeah i mean
a lot of this really is then down to
the funding because
[Music]
for housing to be affordable you have to
have an element of of subsidy and and
that's that's the key so
certainly we work very closely with with
homes england we're always on the
lookout for you know new funding
programs so so absolutely it is it is a
it is open to the council
to do that um
but you you you know in order for that
housing to be affordable there has to be
an element of subsidy and the key thing
is where do you get that subsidy from so
that's where things like the you know um
the affordable housing program
uh come in um but otherwise um
where we are doing our own types of
development then
there is cross subsidy from the market
housing but but you also have to kind of
balance
you know
otherwise you make the the market
housing too expensive for certain so
it's how you balance it out see what i
mean
councillor black ben
thank you can i please um is there any
indication that the housing associations
are extending
any of the properties in their housing
stock
so if if if a tenant requires larger
accommodation so that they can stay in
the community which they might have
lived in for a long time
um they
many of them have got programs of
refurbishment and um
and i think you're absolutely right one
one of the challenges and um is um
is around you know getting the right
size of property
um
an example of that for example is we
have quite a lot or well we have a
proportion
of really quite unsuitable bedsit
accommodation some of that geared
towards elderly people some of it geared
towards single people it's not really
fit for purpose and generally what um
registered providers have been doing is
is where they can is is re
repurposing that
um you may be aware that for example
erwell valley have a big program on sale
west estate at the moment
they're completely redoing a number of
properties we've helped them
gain some more funding recently um
through a state regeneration program
initiative
for that um so yes
a lot of it obviously there's there's a
cost to doing that and so it's
balancing
you know the the ability and the
opportunity to do that with the funding
available but certainly a number of them
do have those sorts of programs
and i was thinking actually not so much
repurposing the the
the you know the um the actual property
that they're in but an extension um you
know because some some people some
families you know they have
more children than they can fit into it
into your
standard three bed
and some properties you know they have
got the um you know the available land
and housing associations can can get um
you know different types of funding i'm
just thinking that you know people if
they want to stay where they live
because of schools and family and
places of religion
and there's there's a larger property
but they've got to maybe
move four or five miles away it's it's
not always it's not always the best
thing
for them
right yeah i see see what you mean i i
think i'm on that particular point i
have to come back to you as to whether
you know if they do i see what you mean
here because if it was a private house
an owner occupation you'd probably just
put a you know put an extra bedroom on
so um i i don't know offhand whether um
how many are doing things like that but
we'll come back to you if that's all
right
if i can just uh chip in on that as well
we see
um
you know in the owner occupied sector um
loft extensions
are going up galore
it's a lot cheaper to do
something like that than it is to move
so it would be interesting to know um
if the
social landlords
are looking at that sort of
scheme to
increase
what they have to offer where families
are growing but the house isn't there's
a problem but if the house can grow
uh with the
tenants uh staying in put because you
the loft extensions get built without
people having to to move out so
i think it's uh it would be worth
knowing a bit more about that
but we'll move on now to councillor
taylor
um
thank you thank you adrian for the for
the for the report which um
which is you know really useful because
it you know
starkly illustrates the you know the
housing problem we haven't we haven't
trafford um my question was about the
allocations policy um and a particular
query about victims of domestic abuse
and this this is based on some case work
i had a while ago where
um
a woman was a victim of domestic abuse
she had she had a young baby
she um
she was in social housing
well in the north of the borough
probably won't say any more than that
she was living with family in the in the
south of the borough and essentially she
she wasn't living in a social housing
she didn't want to go back there because
she was
fearful of a
violent ex-partner and i think so the
problem she had was
she was in one of the lower bands so she
didn't really ha and also
she did have social housing she just
couldn't live there and so i wondered
whether um
there is scope within the allocations
policy or within the banding system
to give some priority to people who are
in that situation um
i think she did get assistance in the
end when i when i contacted
the housing provider and she was given
some more priority but i mean she had a
particularly difficult i suppose they
the particular problem with that is that
she didn't want to live in the north of
the borough because she was worried her
violent ex-partner would find her so
her particular circumstances were really
limiting her housing choice and i just
wonder is there a way to
give people in that position some
priority and also i know there's
reference later on to advice also some
advice on
you know how they can best put
themselves into
housing into a safe environment
thank you
uh
yes well they did
certainly
people uh in that position um
would be um
would be afforded um you know reasonable
preference i mean it does depend on
individual circumstances of course but
um you you can see that um i mean they
could for example be clusters being at
risk of homelessness because obviously
they wouldn't be able to stay in the
home where they were um or it could be
um
it's the bullet point at the top of page
three of the report that um
you know those who need to move because
of um
you know if they weren't able to move
you know they would
be being risk
risk to themselves so
so certainly um
sadly when when we talk about the the
duties of the homelessness duties i
described um
you know one one of the the kind of
principal causes of that
can be um a a difficult um you know
family relationship of various kinds um
so absolutely that that would be taken
into account it's probably a little bit
hard to generalize without because each
circumstance will be different but in
general terms yes you would be you would
get that um you would be bumped up from
your way you know if usa band five but
your circumstances change because of
that then almost certainly you would you
would receive a better preference
councillor taylor then councillor lloyd
thank you again very much for this uh
report really informative and does
highlight the uh
that the immense difficulties we do have
with um housing in trafford um
i noticed i can't remember it was in the
report but you said sometimes some of
the address they might direct people to
um social on as not social landlords
private the private rented sector as
well
um does the council have any um
remit with regulation to private
landlords or is there any plan to
to implement that at all because uh
we
i i have had case work from private um
tenants and uh you know their their sort
of address is quite limited really
uh yeah absolutely we we do we do have a
um duties under that and and um it's
it's it sits within the environmental uh
health
uh department but we do have a a housing
standards team it's a very small team we
would like it to be bigger um
and they are extremely busy but but
absolutely um where there is um you know
unfit uh housing or you know
substandard housing then um
then we have the powers to to intervene
and indeed you know do so um on a you
know fairly regular basis
is there i mean this is something to
sort of consider as council policy that
we maybe um
develop a strategy or
implement a strategy to regulate
landlords in the borough a little bit
more closely really because um there are
frameworks in place and i know they've
been adopted by other boroughs um but
i'm not aware that that's something
that's been adopted by trafford council
yeah it is something we've looked at um
um but there are certain um
thresholds that you um you need to meet
before so so for example various bits of
manchester
um have a system of regulation for the
private rented sector and indeed you
know
other boroughs as well
um but you have to meet um
a couple of thresholds really but you
have to have the right density of the
private rented sector and also evidence
of
um problems arising so
you know a sort of really typical wood
one might be in areas where there's you
know lots of student housing and you get
sort of bins everywhere and and
difficulties like that
um uh
there are other parts of manchester
where they're not related to student
housing but again you know
there's a real preponderance of private
rented
um and some you know other local
difficulties and they've been able to
put in a a regulatory regime
we are not yet at that
level so no parts of
of
trafford currently meet those thresholds
but it is something that we we have
looked at i know councillor wright has
asked us to consider that and we have
been in discussion um with manchester
about you know how that works and all
the rest of it so it is certainly
something that has been looked at but
we're just not quite at that level it
was the conclusion
okay thank you
council lloyd
um can i just uh first of all start by
saying thanks um when i've had um
homeless um on the street if you like uh
people
um reported to me
i've got a reply
quite quickly and in fact they probably
know the person anyway um but they have
been to visit them so i just want to
congratulate you
on that team that um go out to visit
them great
the question
that i would like to ask is some going
on to if if people have been bumped up
and domestic abuse is obviously one of
those veterans is another one that um
you have to look at
that means people are going down on the
list
a little bit and how many
if you like referrals perhaps you get
the add to the housing list
all every year
every year because
i know you're supposed to one of these
criteria is you're supposed to have some
um
some connection to traffic but obviously
some people don't
and it may be in the paper and i may
have missed it but i did try to read it
right um well no
thank you very much for for the thanks
and and i should stress it is it's the
housing option service traffic so known
as hosts who uh who are the team that
will will go out and and and speak to
people um so i suppose in terms of um
you know where people are afforded
higher priority and you're quite right
so so veterans for example uh are
generally within five years of an
honorable discharge um given have sort
of bumped up a band um according to
their circumstances
um
so there are obviously various
circumstances as described where people
are given higher preference
that doesn't mean that somebody
in that band is then bumped down but i
suppose what it does mean of course is
that there is perhaps more competition
for the housing that arises and i i
guess that's um inevitable um i thought
we had put in here the numbers of
um
applicants and i think it's the table at
4.6
um
so that show yeah so i think that's
shows how many how many applicants we we
get uh overall so about six and a half
thousand
yes
is it added so next year will it be
seven thousand is
oh i see so is the is the total number
of people on the on the register growing
or
yes right i
don't think i have that information to
hand so i can i'm sure we will have it
so i'm sure i can add that to the list
to provide if that's all right
just uh um associated with that point it
is the
um
is that gross number that main list is
that refreshed
frequently to to make sure that there
aren't
people on the list who actually got
themselves sorted out somewhere and not
bothered to let anybody else know
um yes there is um that there is a
refreshment i'm sorry i'm trying to
think how regularly that's done but i
take your point yes because obviously
people in the lower bands may well put
themselves say well you know i want to
apply for something and and they they
will find their own accommodation or
they'll move away and and so on so um
i'm sorry a chair if i can perhaps have
that also to the list and so how
frequently it's refreshed
last one for me um can i just ask
because i thought linda's point
uh was interested in counseling
backgrounds about extensions
um it's the housing associations if
you're disabled
and you need um quite a lot of work to
be done so for example
if they've got a bath and they can't get
in the bath or something
will they
will those
adjustments be made can the works be
done or do they have to be rehoused
somewhere else
um it will very much depend in terms of
kind of the adjustments you know could
the adjustments be made to the existing
home um it probably depends how
extensive um
you know their needs are um so so you
know the kind of conventional uh things
that people might be able to do in a in
an average home um would be done
but of course there may be circumstances
where people can't um you know for
example if you have real stiff mobility
difficulties and you're on say a first
or second floor flat
then clearly that's going to create
great difficulties for you so you so
you'll see that um
[Music]
when we talk about
um there's a
it's a paragraph 3.3
um
applicants who need to move on medical
or welfare grounds or on grounds of
disability so so there may be
circumstances where it's just not
possible to adapt a house
and therefore
that they get preference uh
that gives you a high preference
priority for uh finding new suitable
accommodation so so yes it does it does
mean that you you should
fairly quickly be able to get um you
know the right accommodation for you
diane did you want to come in on that um
it was just to support that really so
council lloyd and we do offer a moving
grant so if somebody does need to move
because we can't adapt to property or
the landlord doesn't feel it's
appropriate to do that then we do offer
a moving grant of 3 000 pounds to
support the move and to an alternative
property and we work really closely with
the landlords to try and make sure we
can maximize the
people to remain in their own home and
but where where a move is required we
put quite a lot of support around people
to do that
just a couple of questions from me then
um i think we've covered
questions from the committee um
the the three main um registered social
landlords that you're dealing with um
have you generally got good working
relationships with them or is there any
sort of tension
over
the fact that
we're stumping in saying
uh we've got people to put in your
houses
um well for for the most part um
registered providers are are really
quite um uh glad to have a nomination
agreement because of course it means
that their properties get get filled and
and you can see from the um
you know the the success rate that
generally that working relationship is
is good um
of course
members most will be aware that uh
trafford housing trust is is now um part
of a much bigger group so the l and q
group which was originated in london
um so there are changes afoot of course
for that organization um
but uh but absolutely generally um you
know we're able to to allocate
um people and that works pretty well
because as i say those success rates in
terms of attendances show that generally
people are getting to the properties the
right kind of properties
and you mentioned tht and that it's not
just there um
being part of a
much bigger virtually national
group now that they're also developing
beyond
traffic boundaries
aren't they i don't know if those are
properties for rent or for sale but
is there a
do they limit with what they will deal
with trafford on
to properties that are within trafford
or do they go beyond the trafford
boundaries for those people on the
trafford list
um in terms of that are our nominations
our nominations are the properties in
trafford um
so um most of these uh well all of those
big big
ones on on on the list and pretty much i
imagine i think every registered
provider
will have properties in in in other
areas um
and many of them also now have a kind of
a semi-private sort of development arm
as as well
um
none of that
i would say really um impacts on their
ability to
um
you know
accommodate people in in trafford um
uh
you know really i suppose what we're
always looking for is to ensure that our
stock is properly maintained and where
there's the opportunity to get it you
know improved like the sort of program
that erwell valley are doing in sail
west then you know that's what we want
to be encouraging them to do is wherever
they are
investing
we want to make sure that they're
investing here in trafford so so that's
what we try and do
thank you now just a quick question on
on the
on the rough sleepers i mean those
numbers that you're showing there are
thankfully
very low
um
but those people aren't necessarily
jumping up and down and shouting i'm a
rough sleeper are they when the count is
done
are we are we confident that
we're finding the hidden ones
do we are we are we sure enough for
those numbers that um we can take
confidence from them
we do have a regular rough sleepers
count um i mean i couldn't pretend that
you know we can be absolutely 100 sure
that we capture everybody
but experience you know
the housing officers do know by
experience where people tend to go
um
and it
you know it is i suppose it's done on a
regular basis
um i mean i couldn't you know hand on
heart i couldn't say that you know every
time we go out do we capture and can we
be sure we capture absolutely everybody
and you know it's a big borough and we
probably couldn't be sure of that but
certainly
um i suppose because it's been done over
a number of years
and we do know the sort of places
typically where people tend to go
then hopefully each time we go out we
are capturing you know we are
reasonably confident with catching
capturing everybody
could you just fast please at the
beginning of them sorry at the beginning
of lockdown
um trafford took in some rough sleepers
from manchester is that still the case
um
the that was probably i'm trying to
think of the program because we we had
there was there was a
um you're absolutely right there was a
program uh gm wide to to accommodate
people
we do um
uh
we certainly through um
some of the programs of the bed every
night and also
um just in terms of people under the
homeless duty we certainly do
accommodate within trafford uh
some of the residents of manchester who
fall under that homelessness duty uh and
so some of the temporary accommodation
that manchester relies on
is in trafford so we so we are taking
manchester um people who are either were
homeless or at
a great risk of homelessness
well thank you
for that
good report and a lot of good questions
and and very um useful answers to that
and as you said at the beginning
about the the link to health
um
we obviously can see that important
thread that
goes through
all that all that we're looking at
in this report so
thank you very much for
for that and uh for all your help to the
committee tonight thank you thank you
thank you councils
okay then so it's uh item seven the
integrated care system locality program
update and we have sarah radcliff and
tom maloney
thank you chair um i'll just quickly
introduce it and then tom will outline
it and we'll answer any questions from
the committee
so um as people will know two days
before christmas we went into a national
delay for the establishment of the
integrated care systems across england
we were obviously
quite busy at the time in a pandemic
booster program and we'd already
redeployed a lot of our staff in order
to do that
so that was going on at the same time
what this actually means is that instead
of the establishment of the icb on the
first of april it will be established on
the 1st of july everything else remains
the same so it's just a 12-week delay
and because there wasn't parliamentary
time to get it through in time so that's
why that has happened um so we've done
as
we stated last time a lot of work had
already been done in trafford so we've
just kept that work program going as you
will see
um all of our staff below board level so
that's about 100 staff in trafford is
about 2 000 across gm they will all lift
and shift and now they will do that for
the first of july with their contractual
status
um
the risk and i know i was asked the risk
last time i was here and i said this
little risk we're doing lots and lots of
work it will be okay um the risk now
with the delay is we will start to lose
more people because of uncertainty um
where we didn't have that length of
uncertainty before so that is now a risk
for us in terms of those um that
is now six months from now until
obviously july
in terms of our board level we'd
actually given notice to our board
because the board has been
disestablished for april so board
members have been given notice
except for the officers the three
officers involved at board level
all their roles will lift and shift but
without role so they are at risk of role
and losing their roles obviously
that consultation and process starts on
monday
to see across gm for those group of
people together across gm that's 52
people that are affected by that three
of them in trafford
and that will be consultation for what
is called the place leader role and
that's a place leader for each of the
boroughs
for health and social care so that will
happen the time lay timeline for all the
appointments is in the paper so i won't
go through that but it has had a
knock-on effect it's knocked into sort
of february and march because of the
delay in order to do that
the consequence for the ccg is that
where we had plans to be disestablished
on the 1st of march we are now not
disestablished
so we are having to put a slimmed down
governing body in place which we will do
according to the 2012 act so we will do
that in order to
fulfill our statutory duties between
april and june so that will happen and
that will be in place so that will carry
on we will as the paper outlines we will
put a lot of the shadow arrangements
that we've already got up and running
they will run
through april and june and a lot of the
work that we will do in quarter what's
termed quarter one of the year will be
in those new arrangements so we will
parallel run in effect um so that we can
actually get to the first of july
as a shadow but in order to function on
what we're calling day one of the icb in
july
um so we can answer um tom will quickly
run through chair just the critical
points in the report and then we can
answer any questions that you might have
around the program of work thank you
thanks sarah and uh thanks colleagues um
just a few points to dry out of the the
report um and not to go into to any any
depth i think we did some of that the
previous meeting um back in november um
just to highlight the um gm operating
model which has now been coming draft
through the joint planning and delivery
committee um which has helped formed our
locality operating model draft which
we've been taking into uh recent
partnership boards in particular the one
system board our locality board here in
trafford um and the main elements of
that are covered within the contents of
this paper
and i'll just cover a couple of those
things now that's also being used in the
um proposed local check and challenge
process which we think will be enacted
uh probably in early february and that's
that sort of peer review process
although we don't know the detail of how
we move towards and day one operating
effectively um
as we intend to do as a system
and
in terms of local developments the one
system board locality board now has
agreed its terms of reference i think
that's a really good step forward with
the caveat that there may be some
changes required between now and march
but we have a self-imposed deadline of
march which we wanted to stick to anyway
in the first place before the delay
about having a final set of terms of
reference that's really important so
that it connects with the terms of
reference of the pro provider
collaborative board and the traffic
clinical and practitioner senate
um as well as having
clarity on terms of reference um for the
foreseeable months we have also as a one
system board responded uh just before
christmas which i think was after the
november uh meeting of this committee uh
to the icb draft constitution we've fed
back our position as a trafford system
not as a local authority or a ccg but
coming together as a system um to
generally support the important aspects
contained within the constitution
um in terms of hr transition i think
sarah has picked up the main points um
that are covered within the paper and
the delay doesn't mean anything to the
employment commitment which we talked
about at the previous committee meeting
one thing it has done is just delayed
slightly the conversations the quality
conversations we need with partners
around what we described as phase two
and that's that transition ways of
working so how the ccg staff and its
functions and its teams will align and
work with other organizations that make
up
our one system board and that is doing
that will be done through a series of
workshops and it's also uh being carried
out through series of one-to-one
conversations with key directors from
key organizations
there is some information in the paper
um about the makeup of the ccg functions
and that's been shared with our partners
and that is forming the basis of the
conversations we're having over the
coming months
importantly just to draw your attention
to um sarah very quickly touched on it
is the place leader
i think very helpful and now as a
trafford system again through our one
system board we've come to a position
whereby we're clear on what our
expectations are of that role um in
terms of its leadership characteristics
which i think in the paper are laid out
quite clearly
and its duties uh and importantly the
position that we've agreed at one system
board around the place leader being
accountable to the icb but absolutely
having a very very strong dotted line
into um in particular traffic council's
corporate leadership team working
closely with um clt
and and importantly all of the other
forums uh to make sure that we can for
example pick up adrian's plans around
tackling the wider determinants such as
health so health and housing
and so really really
important that they're rooted in
trafford um but importantly accountable
to the icb
excuse me um
another really good step forward um
although there's a short-term game here
and a long-term uh plan is around the
inside service reporting so particularly
on the finances and committee members
last time uh raised some concerns and
some questions really positive ones and
constructive ones around the financial
arrangements that the icb
creation um will mean for us here in
trafford
and there are a set of principles and
key points that have been laid out
across greater manchester within the
operating framework about what that
means for trafford we've helpfully come
back to that and developed our own set
of principles and in table three under
4.16
we've tried to articulate what we think
those services are that's our insight
and we're
having constructive conversations with
all our partners through our established
ics finance working group around what
those services would be
and you can see in the table without me
listing them through there but it shows
that actually the breadth of that
equates to a lot of money and actually
it is about encouraging that shared
stewardship which is um a key uh a key
term that we are using um but it
actually sets the tone for how we want
to operate as a health and social care
system in trafford
um i've already alluded to the provider
collaborative board in its terms of
reference and again and that's really
critical uh to be
linked to the one system board we are
developing that critical path for uh the
provider collaborative it's the first
time
that it's met in october diane um and uh
jill heaton are now formerly the
co-chairs of that group which i think is
a fantastic position to be in and i
think it shows the maturity of
relationships in our local system and
will only benefit us in the long term
um
again an important point raised last
time was around communications and
engagement and then the real importance
of the public voice in the planning
design and delivery of health and social
care services we have a working group
and the timing just slightly unfortunate
for today's
committee meeting um because we've had
the working group this afternoon but the
intention is that a draft proposal with
some firm recommendations around how we
shift the dial on engagement utilizing
all the assets of our partners and not
remaining um within our organizations um
is going to the one system board in
february um and if the timing had been
right we could have brought some of
those recommendations here to outline
that in a little bit more detail more
than happy to come back at another point
and work through what that means
um and those are probably
the main points from a locality
perspective
thank you
kevin lloyd
um how long
is parliamentary time being given to
this i know it's in the lords at the
moment but given that of the uh bill is
a bit light on detail
and the
um person in the lord yesterday was
asking one of the questions i would have
been asking
is about doctors because you didn't say
very much about except for
retention um
and i believe there are a lot of gps who
are
coming up to retirement or perhaps don't
want to work particularly
um
and
it does concern me so it's that
parliamentary time because it can be
delayed if if for example
uh you have another variant of kobe
coming along if you have some more
uh problems in parliament um
uh partygate or whatever
um and so it's it's i'm concerned about
the timetable i think that's the first
question
so just in terms of that counselor lloyd
we've asked the question whether there
is a possible
another delay and we've been told at the
moment that it isn't forecast to be so
but in terms of parliamentary time and
what that means and what might happen in
the laws at going back to the commons i
i don't know we've just been told we
need to work towards um implementation
for the first of july
thank you and there appears to be um in
the legislation something about
increasing beds is that right because i
know we've been decreasing them will we
have an increase in beds
so in terms in terms of what we're
looking at each system will look at what
it needs in terms of capacity to
undertake its system requirements so in
terms of the new icb they'll be working
around a provider federation board in
terms of that so looking at the bed
capacity across gm but within the
accountable trusts so i would say
we need to wait and see what that means
for us in terms of what that means in
terms of capacity there's lots of issues
at the moment around our elective our
surgery
workforce is a big issue in terms of you
can have as many beds as you want but if
you haven't got the workforce you can't
actually
put people in your beds um so in terms
of that so again i think it's looking at
what that means for gm as we get to that
point um but i don't know if tom you
wanted to come in as well
yeah
only because this crops have been a
conversation over the last couple of
days and um and people may be getting
confused so the um
the nhs planning guidance which has
recently come out and which were we're
taking through our provider
collaborative that diane shares i'm
putting the nhs plan alongside all the
other plans that we have for adult
social care for the vcsc sector and so
on and so forth um and understanding how
we prioritize and work together and to
deliver the asks within all the relevant
sets of guidance and one of the big
pieces of work there is on virtual
virtual beds and there was just some
confusion in another meeting and another
partnership meeting a number of days ago
around that that may be something that
has cropped up but that is around
virtual beds not physical beds which
would go against that whole living well
at home policy that we've had in
trafford for for many years at diane's
obviously championed and delivered
okay um the other thing is um a comment
really on page 20 of the main report
concerns
about the locality representation of
public health
and i think you think you said that you
have some concerns about that
so i would just share
your concerns because it is important
public health
with
that is part of the health
bit if you like in our localities
so just on that counselor lloyd the
director of public health will have a
seat on the locality board to make sure
in terms of strategy
it will feed in in terms of population
health and service modelling into the
provider collaborative and diane's also
leading on a piece of work at the moment
around health and wellbeing board
and lga peer reviewers coming in to see
how that links as well so that we do
have a really
broad population view as we go into the
trafford local icb um in terms of doing
that and that was one of the reasons why
we really wanted to anchor this new role
that will be within the sort of a wider
corporate leadership team of the council
so it's anchored in it's not accountable
too but it will be anchored into it so
that we can actually look at population
health as well as sitting with
colleagues on public health housing etc
for that wide reform so it's not seen as
a
service
nhs role it's seen as a role that links
into a wider forum
thank you just to follow up on council
lloyd's question actually about the
governance and the same bit in the
report on page 20.
so i i understood this to be concerns
about the
constitution of the
of the icb and
and i understand those concerns because
i think is the point that
um
all 10 localities need to be represented
sort of at that level so i get you know
the concern for for trafford is is
always that um
trafford is thought of as a
you know the most well
is the most affluent bearer in gm but
nevertheless you know we have extreme
health inequalities so i guess the
concern is always
will traffic as a locality be
represented at
that level
um
and
similar similar concern i suppose around
public health being represented at that
level because that does seem to be the
driver for
a lot of this and if public health isn't
involved in that level
it would seem to undermine the purpose
of having a you know joined up health
and social care system
so i think that's the last bullet point
that you're looking at right so in terms
of that currently there's a joint
planning and delivery committee um it
has arrangements but they're not
arrangements that are formalized into
the new icb so they're still looking at
that so one of the things that i think
is becoming evident is there does have
to be
local representation from the 10
boroughs um so that's been and i think
um sir richard um being chair designate
of the gm that's been very loud and
clear coming through in terms of borough
representation place representation what
place means et cetera
i think the other thing then is that
wider population view so population also
needs to sit on that executive senior
team as well at the gm so that will
probably be looking at that next
level of executives of appointment to
make sure that that is absolutely in
there and then the population view will
be not only at the um icb level but also
at that partnership group level where
the two linked together and the chair of
that's now been appointed as well into
the icp partnership as well um so it's
the leader of thameside council
in terms of that so i think it's
starting to sort of come through
and because
because the governance isn't working
itself through to its final component
yet there's a few more months to go i
think some of these are actually sort of
sorting themselves out as we sort of go
through month by month really but i
think having richard lease as the chair
has absolutely brought to the fore the
need to have all the localities and that
wider bureau of view
on the committees as we go forward and
we had our meeting with
gm yesterday which was sarah price's
interim chief um answer richard and i
think that came through loud and clear
really didn't it diane in terms of that
meeting the the need for the boroughs to
be represented
and just one more question of mma chair
which is well i think at the last
meeting we
we were interested in
trying to get
a diagram something that something that
would show us the new structure of the
ics because um
no matter how many reports i i read
about it i still find the governance
arrangements ridiculously complicated
uh and that is a concern in in and of
itself i think um
so i think the ability to see that in a
a comprehensible way to the likes of me
um would be really helpful because i
think i think that's important so that
we can
scrutinize
that evolving system and and see how
it's actually going to look
so we can absolutely do that there's
obviously the gm operating model which
we can you know send to you so you can
see the detail of that and come back
with any questions that you might have
um in terms of that whole governance
that is still being worked through such
as what is a joint committee what does
that mean how do we make that happen
we can send you what our local one is
and then how we can actually look to
sort of how that fits into the gm
operating model
but just conscious that things might
change because it is still working
through but we can send you the gm
operating model we can send you our
local model um and we can send you the
sort of wiring document as it is at the
moment we're really conscious we haven't
got a chief exec at gm and when a chief
exec does get appointed hopefully
very soon they will also want to look at
the governance and look at what we're
doing so it is it is a work in progress
but absolutely we can get you those
documents to look at and and let us know
if there's any questions once you've
seen them
counselor gilbert
i'm just a very easy question and please
could you define for me what a virtual
bed is
it's not a term if you want i can define
since my husband was on one um only a
couple of weeks ago um so um
so in response to covid what we have at
the moment so if people are very
vulnerable um so um vulnerable because
of different cancers or whatever
and you have covered you can go on to
what is the virtual ward in a virtual
bed so if i just take the example of
what happened to him because that's
probably easiest
basically into with insure
seeing someone and within sure to
actually get treatment
in terms of doing that and then actually
discharged home but discharged home with
a team so you're in a virtual board but
in your own home and that team is
actually covering you so either through
consultations on the phone or
consultations you know if they actually
need to come into the house etc so
you're kept on a ward in effect but
you're back in your own home in order to
do that as well
if that's just an easy example thank you
appreciated
councillor taylor
thank you very much uh for the updates
and yeah it's a shame that it's been
delayed um
just referring to item 6.6 on page 26
and i think i asked about this last time
about um
public patient and community engagement
are there any actual concrete plans yet
to to share this because this is a this
is a huge
transition isn't it and you know it's
not a straightforward um
um development at all is it you know the
governance is is quite complex and um i
can imagine that there might be concern
in the public at large you know what are
their services going to be affected you
know about them about um those as
members of the public accessing local
services in the same way that um
we have or is there any threat or risk
to the services um how is that plan to
disseminate and include members of the
public in the development of this
thank you if i can come back on that one
so
there's probably a a few things both
it's a greater manchester level and then
at a local level um so locally um
one of the key objectives of our local
working group is to make sure that any
comms that are coming through from the
greater manchester system and from down
national level as well
are communicated as best they possibly
can i think there's always room for
improvement within that i think a lot of
the consultation and engagement has
probably been staff and system focused
as opposed to um at the public and i
think
some of that is due to timing as well
due to so many gray areas and unknown um
unknown elements um and lack of clarity
i think when we do start to get to um to
the business end of the uh the cessation
of ccgs and the implementation of the
icp then i think um the ability to
communicate in a more effective and
targeted way will be a thing
um
one the way in which i think we're
trying to bring to life the five-year
strategy for greater manchester um is
through the development of an aligned
people and community strategy so there's
a people in community engagement
strategy those meetings have just been
mobilized and the initial deadline for
the creation of that was march as you
can imagine trying to create something
and co-produced very importantly
something like that is impossible in
such a short time frame and we fed that
back
and we have been given obviously that
slight extension to do that piece of
work now um and heather as the chair of
healthwatch is actually leading our
contribution to the trafford system um
so
again adopting those principles of
system leadership there so it's not just
officers um so heather's being our link
into that group and bringing that back
in um there is an ability to
play back in all that we know so we know
we can't just start from scratch with
this we have lots of intelligence lots
of information from the people that we
work with and come into contact to uh
within traffic and it's about using that
as our baseline understanding of what
these changes mean for people in
communities and so that's been collated
at the moment with people from the ccg
from people from the council and working
very closely with the community
collective and thrive who are
representing the vcse sector as well as
healthwatch as well so that piece of
work is happening and being fed into the
sort of gm forums uh in order to create
that initial strategy um and i think
they've taken a lead from what we
committed to a couple of years ago when
we created the locality plan in 2019 was
that we said we know this isn't perfect
and we're going to have a year of
engagement to do this piece of work and
get it absolutely right
and listen to people
and let's take a take a step up that
ladder of co-production
gm seemed to be adopting that year of
engagement that we've sort of suggested
is a really sensible thing to do
which is great to see that some of the
approaches we're trying to adopt here
and traffic have been picked up by
others and so that's the intention over
the coming
number of months is to contribute to
that initial strategy which will mean
the communications flow out to
communities and out to people
and then take part in that year of
engagement or whatever they refer to it
as moving forward which will sit
alongside the broader strategy for the
gm ics so there's a lot of work
happening there at a greater manchester
level that we're keyed into
and then locally as i said referred to
before uh if we have probably a bit more
time i could go into some of the detail
around uh the recommendations around how
we streamline and rationalize um the
public and community engagement
throughout all the organizations that
make up our own system board there are
some opportunities to rationalize lots
of patient forums public forums and
using different language
and the main thing that's come out of
the piece of work i've led recently
is that we don't effectively share that
information as best we can so
information and intelligence gathered in
from mastercall who are a provider of
services urgent primary care doesn't
necessarily permeate the walls of
mastercall and go to other organizations
and i think we've now got the joint
forums in which to make that happen um
and share that intelligence so i think
um i think we're on the cusp of of
making a really good stride forward in
this and some of the feedback we had
just in today's meeting from gm
colleagues um
he's saying that we're the only place
that's trying to get community and
public engagement at the forefront of
their locality board it was really
positive to hear a long way to go lots
of recommendations and it will take time
but you know making positive steps i
think if i could just come in um
councillor taylor so
just in terms of everything that tom
said i just think there's two things
there's one about that sort of
governance of the icb and that
infrastructure and really it should be
organizat level which actually you
which is an
should not see a difference if you are
receiving services um and we need to
make sure that that is happening through
things like healthwatch and the
voluntary sector and other advocacy
groups that are sitting on the gm
transitional programme boards etcetera
and making sure that they are holding
the rest of the system to account to
make sure that we do do that in an
appropriate manner and then everything's
tom said that we've done within trafford
over the last few years about our
locality plan and you know co-production
all the things we've been back here over
many years to do and that is being led
by diane um and others in that provider
collaborative and that tom is actually
doing all that work to underpin so that
in trafford that will be the way we work
for if there are service changes but the
whole icb um that sort of you know big
governance change really is sort of
making sure that that is absolutely
tying into those gm transitional
programme board meetings which
healthwatch and and others are on and
from the independent sector as well in
terms of that advocacy voice
okay well thank you very much for your
very extensive answer i think it's quite
reassuring to know that um healthwatch
and the um thrive and organizations like
that who do advocate directly and have
those links with patients and service
users very uh closely are really
involved at a really sort of high and
strategic level really i think that's
that's quite quite reassuring i just
wonder i mean you you you said that
there are going to be calms and there
are ongoing comms and sort of based on
the the methodology that you use with
the locality plan
are there any plans to disseminate it i
don't know maybe i'm over simplifying it
through things like you know local
newspaper or or you know just just
things where it's very accessible and
and presented to people and i don't mean
you know to oversimplify it but you know
very readily accessible ways of um you
know people being able to pick up on
this information so they don't have to
attend a meeting or
you know um
where they can they can
i have to have a microphone quickly and
yeah there's um
it's a really good point actually um and
something that i think we need to
consider in the coming months is
last year we ran the size of bite-sized
learning sessions because this is so
vast and it's so complex and you have to
compartmentalize some of this to really
sort of get get under the skin of it um
and we run a series of bite-sized
sessions with staff from all our
partners including the council the ctg
and everyone who we work with on a
day-to-day basis we're welcome to come
and join those and learn a little bit
around what does provider collaboration
mean what does clinical and practitioner
uh senate look like et cetera et cetera
and i think at a point in time we may
wish to reconsider whether or not
re-running those knowing what we know
now with clearer plans would be a useful
thing to do um
on a real practical basis um to come
back on your question we have a shared
social media platform um which we try to
utilize as much as possible it has been
a bit difficult um given the pressures
of omicron and kovid because we launched
it just before corvid arrived um
and we had a big um proactive set of
campaigns to run through there uh
collectively with all our partners i do
think we could utilize that more as well
so we will be using that moving forward
um i think i'll take back the um the
practical comms bit um into our uh into
our comms leads jamie in particular uh
who can probably give a fuller update on
how we utilize local media both radio
press etc i think we'll also take it
into gm because one of the things we
want to do is to do it on a gm platform
so that if you're picking it up in
bolton it's not going to look different
than it was in manchester and then
people so um we'll absolutely take that
point back into the gm comms which runs
every two weeks
about what is happening on that sort of
news platform brilliant brilliant and
it's really good to hear that trafford's
leading the way in um
you know
at the forefront of that really so thank
you very much
that's right
uh just as a follow-up to that can we
ensure that um all communication is done
in accessible form as possible and
consider other languages as well and
those who um
you've not got a great reading age
council blackburn
um thank you
community engagement strategy um it's
got currently healthwatch trafford are
our representatives does that mean they
won't be
later on
it's just they put you included the word
currently as though it's
that yeah it might just be a language
thing yeah they're they are they are our
representative uh for the group that it
is time limited the group um so they are
they are playing into that at this
moment in time yeah but it's not they're
not going something sinister about it no
absolutely and we've awesome they're
also a member of the locality board
so
okay if i may just ask then a clearly um
complex piece of change that's uh
being been
put through here
sarah what's your biggest concern
about what still needs to be done
i think at the moment my biggest concern
is
around getting the leadership in place
as soon as possible because then we can
get all those other things in place
which we've been talking about really
the fact that we didn't appoint to a
chief exec when other places did
was a concern
so really we we need to appoint this
time round um and then we can start to
get the other leadership posts in place
even though the staff
it's what is called a lift and shift and
so people you know know that they will
have a contract and stuff they want to
know where their teams are and they want
to know who's going to lead them and
they want to know what that means and so
the consultations around that getting
that in place we need to do as soon as
possible really
it does feel it's been going on for a
long time um to be quite honest and the
delay um
you know
it puts more risk into the system um
we're getting more people leaving now
whereas before we were very stable in
trafford um because we've done a lot of
the work so that's my biggest risk
really
chair we just need to get the leadership
in place now
okay thank you and and thank you both of
you for
very
detailed reports on a very complex area
um
obviously a lot to do um but i think
i've i feel a confidence that the job is
in very good hands so thank you for all
that you're doing and thank you for what
you've shared with us tonight
thank you chair much appreciated and
also the sport is much appreciated it's
um it's not an easy road we travel
through the pandemic whilst trying to do
this as well so thank you very much
thank you chair thanks everyone thank
you
okay so then um
the committee work program to discuss
the
committee
work program and suggest items for
future
meetings
so i've dropped right in at a deep end
on this one and i can see from the
information that we've got
with the agenda that there are some
items that
appear to be a little bit overdue
what i was planning to do was to
not decide anything on those particular
points tonight but to take that away and
and have a
discussion with the um
vice chairman deputy chairman
my colleague my colleague
and and
uh take a look at what uh what to deal
with there but
uh as well as that welcome any
suggestions from
the
members here if there's any
points that you
can see on that list or
perhaps a another topic that you feel
may be relevant for us to
perhaps have a
a bit of a look at
realize i've dropped that right on you
in this in the way a lot of stuff's been
dropped on me recently but um don't feel
obliged to answer now um because we can
just if you do want to
give it some thought and and and let us
know and we can put that into the
discussions if you want to
say something alex uh just note that um
one of the earlier items um from diane
eaton she said that you would like to
come back with an update around that
framework whether it would be continuing
or it would be
taken out of um
commission um
at the next meeting so that's one item
already i think on that okay
thank you
judith
um
it's to do with the health inequalities
one of the things that concerns me is
that every time you have a
reorganization of the health service it
slows things down not only that we've
also got a slowdown of um services like
people are having to wait longer for
operations
but there are other conditions that need
to be um looked at
and i just want
for example diabetics um
people who've got heart problems and
things like that i just wonder how they
are getting on in the system or are they
being so delayed
um and it will it's it's to do with
health inequalities because it's
the people who've got the worst health
outcomes are the ones who
really
do have the health inequalities as well
um so i just want to have we've not been
told
how things are moving um if you like in
going back to normal
um and i know
it can't go back to normal
straight away
but i do wonder how quickly people are
now moving through this
the health services
okay thank you
linda you went
um
i know
because either last meeting or the one
before last march jarvis came
and you know i remember asking him about
you know gp surgeries gps
and
i wasn't really happy with the the reply
that i got you know everything's fine
and dandy and that's my gp's all singing
all dancing which it isn't
and
and i know obviously we're still in the
pandemic but
something as basic as
your local gp surgery
doesn't seem to be your local gp surgery
anymore
and that relationship that you've got
with your gp seems seems to have gone
and contact with the gp surgeries is so
very very difficult and i just feel that
it's it's something that we really need
to to look at because it's it's it's the
basis of
all our communities
so can i just ask you then um more than
just you linda to ask the room
because i obviously i wasn't at
the meeting that referring to where um
the gp
the service from gps was discussed as i
understand
um
was there is there generally a feeling
that
he didn't
get to where he wanted to be
with that
that the small to go out
um
well having tried asked my gp since then
i can understand people's frustrations
you know thankfully i don't have that
much contact with my gp but i did try
and use it and it it was ridiculous i
was expecting to sit by the phone you
know the whole morning in case the gp
filmed you know whilst i'm trying to
work um anyway um so yeah i agree i
agree with um i agree with linda about
that and i
we had on the on the plan uh we had a
task and finish group
around
um identifying general practices at risk
of failing and i don't think we ever did
that i don't see any outcome from that
so
there might be a piece of work around
that was in the light of them
a number of practices in the north
library closing and i think um
i think the experience from the pandemic
has been
it does illustrate that when a practice
closes it is really disruptive because i
know there were
problems early on in the pandemic in
tracing people because data hadn't gone
across to the new practice et cetera so
yeah i think there's probably a piece of
work for us to do around
access to general practice now and then
also
um you know the risk of practices
failing and
sort of the resilience of the system
isn't it in in really
you know really hard times i suppose um
so we keep that as two
items okay yeah i'm asking you all
yes
they are different where i'm sitting
they are different aren't they yes but
yeah one is about access now you know
remote access yeah apparently in the
pandemic sort of world and the other is
about
risk of practices failing and how we
deal with that yeah yeah
well that sounds like two very good
topics
the
sort of stuff i think that this
committee should be looking mm-hmm
and we did we did look at that didn't we
okay do you remember but that was
pre-pandemic do you remember about risk
of practices failing do you remember we
it was it was and but that was pretty
pandemic wasn't it i think that was
going back to maybe 2019 or certainly
early 2020 wasn't it um because we just
did that as a it was a singular meeting
really wasn't it where we we brought i
remember um mark jarvis and i remember
some others being there anyway and we
sort of interrogated and we came away
feeling that at that time you know that
general practice was in
in better shape than it had been but
obviously you know the pandemic has
changed everything hasn't it really you
know maybe it's timely to to review that
because i agree with you linda that you
know
gp or access to gp is probably it's the
front door isn't it to accessing all
services beyond that really you know
that is your first port of call isn't it
with any concern about your health in
any any way really so maybe it's timely
to um to to do you know another um
interrogation of what's happening
currently in gp world isn't it yeah
i mean at that time we were particularly
looking enough in north of the borough
yeah we'd had a number of practices shut
down and that's what we were focusing on
so i do think it is time to look
there's been a lot of changes huge
amounts of changes yeah
you know the way that we engage with our
gps has changed tremendously hasn't it
in the last two years so
well if there's that particular point
you made there that
um a lot happened
in the last two years it'd be good for
us to look at how it's sitting now
wouldn't it
i think it's got to the stage though
where they're telling you you've got to
ring at eight o'clock like the old days
yeah and if you're angry at two minutes
past eight hard luck it's it's it's
you can't get an appointment and then
you try the next day and they've gone i
actually wrote a letter and handed it in
to the practice
because i said i'm sorry to sorry to
bother you but i can't
get to speak to a gp
and they did come back to me the
following day i said well thank you very
much for english
it's take me a week and in the end i
wrote the letter and walked in and
handed it but um you know not everybody
can ring at eight o'clock in the morning
you know particularly if you're not
feeling well
let's not rehearse it now
save all those good points
i think though we've got to accept that
gp services um all the pandemic has done
is um
hastened on
um some of the uh changes that were
gonna happen so like telemedicine and
stuff like this rob and having a you
know a phone call um which actually but
that can work
that's how it's working but actually
it's not the john lewis that they used
to talk about service that you that you
were supposed to have because actually
there's no
if you like sense that you may be
working or you've gone to work um and
you've got a job or
you know
you've got other things to do
the whole yeah the whole system in
general practices it's flawed it's 50
years out of date but no government will
have to tackle it that's my view but
i um
i think i think there's something in do
this do this point other point as well
about um
delays delays particularly in secondary
care um i think because i suppose one of
the big drivers of health inequalities
is
the number of years you spend in poor
health and you know if you're waiting
for a hip replacement or you know other
surgery treatment then you're you're
spending longer in poor health so i
think
it would be good to look at
you know what's the
what's the state of play in terms of
waiting times for surgery you know
non-covered stuff how long are people
waiting and what steps are being taken
to improve that
exactly yeah i think all of these are
really good suggestions i'm i'm just
going to suggest maybe counselor wetland
maybe yourself and um alex and and i
maybe just
have a little look at the original plan
that we set for the year and maybe uh
review that i mean i think a lot of
these would would sort of fit in with
that anyway look if there's there are in
sort of areas of outstanding um
you know uh questions or um objectives
that we've either not met or we said
that we wanted to uh and and see see
where we're we're up to i mean you know
these are
i'm sure these ideas would fit into it
and um maybe we could share that with
the committee and if there's a you know
and see how and put a draft programme
together for next time because it's the
9th of march isn't it and that'll be the
last meeting of the municipal year so we
can sort of tie up and and just sort of
evaluate how effective we have been this
year does that sound like a
and and then we can we can meet and sort
of put together a program does that
sound reasonable to do that i mean i
think we've got loads of ideas i mean we
we did in march 21 have uh it was
particularly around tackling health
inequalities a focus on diabetes and i
noticed that one of the actions was to
come back in 12 months time and and
report back on how that was progressing
do we need a an update on that or do you
want to look at it a bit more widely in
terms of
you know you said about delays to
surgery or other services that have
maybe
been overlooked not overlooked but um
certainly been delayed and
because of covered
what do you think
i was just gonna i'm
i'm getting the feeling that we're
building up a good list here but quite a
bit
yeah and and i i don't want to
uh dismiss stuff because we feel like
we're building up too big a list so i'm
going to chance my arm here now and just
say if it comes to it that we need to
uh
get a further meeting
put in the
diary
what's the views
about about that i know it's another
couple of hours of everybody's time a
bit more with the preparation but um
[Music]
but it's also we're going to have
currently a scrutiny review going on uh
which will restructure um
the way that we do a lot of like the
work programming and planning everything
out for the year um
so i mean it probably
i mean
i don't know how much you get out of
having an additional meeting and also
you're going to be looking at getting
everything in place and preparing like
the whole scrutiny function for
um
going into a new way of doing things in
the in the future well i was just
really responding to the ideas that come
forward and that and
i think that
this almost an urgency about
some of those
and
it would be a shame that we
didn't
have a look at them
because we
felt
that we couldn't cram it all into that
march meeting
would there be scope for you say may but
would there be scope for an april
meeting
uh april will be very difficult i mean
um
we've gone down to one scrutiny officer
which is myself um i'm also got some
leave booked in in the next couple of
weeks uh so there's
not really going to be a lot plus when
it comes to election time um the
governance team we provide support
throughout that so it would be um quite
a big ask on i mean we do have two new
appointees as part of our team but
they're both new appointees so
like just in terms of resource we're
just kind of struggling at the moment to
fulfill like those additional
requirements
but i can take it back um to my manager
and ask around what the possibility is
and can look at that and i can get you
an answer on that um pretty swiftly well
i suppose if it moved into may but it
was before the
agm of the council then it
would be like planning committee it
would be this
group of people plus the others
uh who would be eligible to
attend
it yes the health and uh the health and
wellbeing board holds a meeting in in
may pretty much every year in between
the election and the agm and they work
on that kind of principle
because even
yeah maybe anyone who
leaves obviously would not be in that
um position but um yeah i think you
still have a quorum
as long as
i've not
proposed anything that uh
anybody's got any violent objections to
we'll
we'll take away what
we've
talked about in this
piece here now and
the three of us will
come in and work on that and
we'll keep you informed about
what we uh what we come up with
can i just ask is there a way of
checking that there isn't going to be
something we're going to be looking at
that gm might be also scrutinizing at
the same time so we're not doubling up
on the same work
is there a are you able to do that there
is a gm health scrutiny committee isn't
there yeah
well uh they've sent the public to
a
uh
gm
meeting very much really hasn't it
i haven't been to meeting for a long
long time they've struggled with the uh
the pandemic again they've had so many
meetings um cancelled and then
when they have convened them they've not
been quarried so um yeah it has been a
big struggle i don't think they've
managed
um many meetings but they're all
available online so i can check that as
well and check their work program make
sure we're not doubling up on things
that they're doing and the other thing
is as well that some of the other
councils for example manchester council
not gm
did something about dentistry and so for
example i wouldn't suggest we do
dentistry because they've already told
us
what i think we could come to the
conclusion is anyway that it's really
difficult to get a dentist
and i think unless we're going to make
um recommendations or differences i
don't think we should
i think it would be interesting to find
out what other people are doing so we
don't
um
go down that path when we don't need to
if you like
yeah i think that's a really good idea i
mean something i don't want to again add
to the agenda because we've got more
than enough to uh to work our way
through but something that has concerned
me and i'm sure all of you over this
time is the impact that the pandemics
had on young people i think they have
been particularly hard hit i think
elderly people and and young people
particularly um you know those of school
age have really really suffered through
this pandemic and i'd be just really
interested to get some um maybe some
evidence from organizations like cams
um you know in terms of of their
responsement it's very very difficult
isn't it to to to access cams really but
to just get a feel for you know the the
mental health of i mean i know
anecdotally could probably tell us a lot
of stories but go on linda i think
that's picked up with cyps
really yeah so yeah i think our meetings
next next week right is that something
you're you're looking at then
maybe right yeah that would be helpful i
mean you don't want to duplic either
duplicate the work of another committee
or you know if it's been done elsewhere
in gm you know um we could maybe get the
evidence from there couldn't we you know
we don't want to to duplicate would you
look into that then maybe linda is that
something you could have a little look
at yeah thank you
all right i'll uh
at this point then closed meeting and
can i just thank everybody for their
attendance for the contribution and for
the way you conducted yourself because
it made my job a lot easier i tried to
say thank you to your counselor because
you got thrown in this quite short
notice didn't you so thank you for
sharing so so well it's such a you know
such lo so late in the day
thank you thank you very much
so surely
do you think to me because if you're